got the me i got the uh
amendment in and um
unfortunately i'm not i don't have a uh
hard hard copy to work off of hopefully
it'll get it'll get here when
when it does but why don't i start the
uh
start the start the meeting everybody
all set
are you ready to go jamie yep reporting
is all set for you chair
okay we all set everybody hear us
right okay let me try
let me go let me uh read the read the
script
as chair of the house resources
recreation and development committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor and as a result
of the kovit 19 and in accordance with
the house rule
67 and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
220 executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is an executive session on senate
bill 146.
please note that there are no physical
location for members of the public
to observe and listen to
contemporaneously
to this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order i am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through zoom electronic meeting platform
and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information have
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website
notice for this meeting
[Music]
the notice for this meeting notice
complies with house rules
and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should call 271 3600
or email hcs at
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that is
meeting assisting
us brad greenland committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
with that i will ask the clerk to call
the world
thank you mr chair um
representative corrigan omen alone
my representative uh i am president i am
in my office and currently alone
representative creighton i'm president
in the committee room representative
dodge
president and alone here
representative home office and alone
representative mayville i am present and
alone
president post i am present at the
lp office representative smith
present and alone representative spain
present and alone representative
i'm president and my wife is in the
house
present alone representative cohen
i am present and alone
representative i'm president
and alone representative connors
president alone representative hill
representative bale i'm here
and i'm alone representative kelly
i'm here and alone representative moran
i'm here alone representative murder
president here in the committee room
representative
president here in the lobby
um here uh in the committee room
we have everyone
thank you very much uh
what we are here for is to exec
house bill 146.
it's an omnibus bill it has
hold on for a second
this is the hard copy of the amendment
well thank you pardon me for
for uh stopping but now i finally have
i can i can finally read the amendment
that i've been waiting for
uh the
house bill or send it to me senate bill
is an omnibus bill and
it started off with
six parts
three of which were
with a purview of the resources
committee
two are with a purview of the fish and
game committee
and one was the purview of uh
the ena environmental and agriculture uh
we have had hearings
on the each of those sections and also
we have
and we are there also there was a
hearing on a non-germane amendment
that we also had so that that will
that is now attached to there will be
attached to the bill
with this with this amendment so
to go just so you have
on your screens uh amendment number
uh 1573 but first i think i should uh
request
uh uh representative
brighton uh if you would uh if you would
uh
give me a uh i would accept the motion
to ought to pass as amended for
house bill assuming senate bill 146.
uh mr chairman uh i motioned that we
uh vote ought to pass on
senate bill 146. out the password
motion by uh by representative creighton
uh
second seconded by representative smith
now that's that is just to get it out on
the floor
i think i'd like uh we need we should
discuss
the amendment as it as it exists
uh and
also the the bill itself
uh this is this is my the my first crack
at
uh at an omnibus bill
so bear with me uh
the
uh the and the um okay the amendment
the uh okay uh
the changes that you've seen that have
been made to senate bill
uh 146 were
as follows the
original bill had a part two in it
that part two uh
concerned the solid wastewa waste
disposal
and a solid waste disposal goal
that uh and we had uh
a joint hearing with
ena to go over that bill
that bill uh that's or that absolutely
that part
of the uh of the uh of the bill
that was part two that has been
uh removed that
what has happened with that bill uh with
with my blessing is
the contents of part
of part two was added to
a a an ena bill
in the that is still in the possession
of the of the senate
uh this was and
the part two was uh the the contents of
part two became an amendment to that
bill that was
uh house bill 4-1-3
the amendment was put together by by the
chair
of ena and the uh sponsor of
uh senate bill 140 it was a
friendly amendment there it's uh
and the bill that amendment uh
passed the comm passed the senate
uh energy and natural resources
committee and it was passed by the
senate
and it is uh and the bill where as
amended
uh senate house bill 4 413
is now in the hands of ena
and we are not no longer it's no longer
part of our
purview we're it's no longer part of
this of uh 146.
so that bill is
that part of the bill is no longer
no longer with us it's with some it's
with it's in the
it's in the committee where it ought to
have been in the first place
uh so the fact that
uh that part
two to say this is vacant
we we had we had taken we had uh
uh had a non-jermaine amendment
associated with this bill uh when we had
our hearing
that was a simple uh change of a date
for fire for uh the uh
of the the extending the firefighting
foam take back program uh
that's all is this is the change of a
date that is now
uh the not we'll now be considered call
part two uh
in part three of the bill which is part
of the
fish fish and game uh could uh
uh responsibility uh there was
a the
there was that part three is a
uh issue is a uh
disc that discusses or is a
is a bit is a
is his concerns
uh the prevention of zoonotic disease
transmission
uh and the only change
in that uh
and that that part of the bill and that
part
was a change of a of one
word and the word for was
from uh from
emergency to executive and we
referred to the um
zoonotic means you can
you can you can catch a disa animal from
the transmitted diseases
uh and uh the the uh
the the the part of the uh the change
that we are
we put in and was at the recommendation
of
uh fish and game was to change
a phrase from emergency order
to executive order because
emergency order especially with the with
the uh state of emergency
we were in has a different
connotation those all you really need is
executive order
on part four there
was a significant rewrite
which in that part four is uh
excuse me part four there was nothing no
i'm i'm
i'm a mistake a part four there was
nothing uh no changes there
part five uh which is establishes a
surcharge
on certain salt water licenses
and established a fund for derelict
fishing gear and coastal cleanup
that
that had to be have a significant
rewrite because
there was a amendment submitted by
uh by the sponsor
that uh that made that uh
clarified some language
and uh also there was at the
recommendation
of the fish and game uh
we we changed the name of the uh
of the fund that the that the
monies would go into uh we changed it
uh from
uh uh well it's now
it would it's now called called the uh
derelict fishing gear and coastal
cleanup fund
as opposed to the it also had mentioned
at the time the uh
the it mentioned a another
i think it was called fishing for
freedom
fishing for energy yeah uh fishing for
energy
and uh the that was
a specific source of funding and really
shouldn't have been been shouldn't be
put in the uh
in in the in the in statute uh
finally the uh
let's see and finally we
we have taken
the this is this is new
uh how it's just some of you may know uh
house bill 3 235
addressing the impacts to other
water users from new sources of water
for community water systems this
committee has passed that bill
twice it when it
what the it is before the house uh
excuse me the
it went to the senate they put a
amendment on it concerning uh
they put an amendment on it on the house
version
concerning the pfast uh
uh the pfast
fund where uh
we that is something that we are very
interested
in uh
uh we will be talking about what we
will about what we will be doing with uh
with that uh bill uh when it uh
whether we do a committee of conference
uh or or do a concur or non-concur
or non-concur nest or committee of
conference in preparation for that
we have uh have added as part of this
amendment
uh the the house version
of house bill 235
which is on to this amendment so that
in case the negotiations don't
go well uh um we hope i
hope negotiations go well if we have a
comedian conference but just in case
uh we'll the belt and suspenders
the motion uh part of the amendment
where as part seven will be the
to placing the in the
house text of house bill 235
on this bill so that
those are the changes
uh that uh
uh on that from the amendment now
now to why
first of all i think we i will open it
to discussion
uh uh you can
we've probably uh if you want we can
discuss
the amendment uh i think we will discuss
both the amendment
and the bill at once i would i would
think uh
if there's uh just uh
won't take any vote until uh you know
until we are ready but uh are there any
comments
uh on the amendment and any comments on
the bill
just to clarify this amendment 1573.
uh yes amendment 1573.
any comments on the bill any comments on
the amendment
so um
my concern is um uh section
three uh regarding the um
zoonotic um transmission
um and the um
i feel i feel with this one when i look
at it
and i spoke to a lot of different people
about it and um
came down to talking to actual members
of the fish and game
um that go out there and do the work and
they felt that it was
logistically difficult not enforceable
and they said how are they going to
monitor this wildlife
looking for it i mean um and
they said um they felt that
this was a way to create
health certificates for every animal
coming into this state
and the problem with that again is
enforcement
and tracking it down and manpower issues
and financials um i do feel it's an
overreach of the government we're adding
more um fees and
punitive punitive damages to
folks too and it is a broad
reach in the fact that um
there is nothing that's happening right
now this is not addressing something
that is currently a problem this is
addressing a problem for the future
and i realize they want to put things in
place but
right in the section that we have of
part three it does
say that they refer to the governor if
um executive order is deemed necessary
and if he can do that anyway i see no
point in
us doing this prematurely until the
logistics are worked out
for making this program to be workable
operable by the people that are on the
ground doing the work
and um i feel if they don't see a need
for it i don't know why we should
keep that do understand the limitations
of
you know uh we cannot pull this out
of the bill um and so i find that a
little frustrating i don't know if we
can still do
an amendment to
make some changes to that so that we can
i can vote for the rest of the bill
because i do feel the rest of the bill
is
worth passing um so that's my comments
thank you now you realize that
fish and game testified in favor of it
right and the fish and game
committee uh
was unanimously in favor of it
yes i do realize that thank you
any other questions representative smith
um actually uh thank you mr chair
for taking my question and a comment
also the who
has called for a ban of the sale of live
wild mammals in food markets to prevent
the emergence of new diseases
so if that's something that's going to
be happening um
[Music]
being recommended worldwide to prevent
the spread of diseases
like you know salmonella
cobalt whatever i mean just all
different kinds of things it seems like
we would just be kind of
setting up a program for that to happen
and as far as the governor's
um executive powers
um in dur as we've seen in the last year
a lot of people have said the
legislature should have some say
in what goes into executive orders and
this
would actually put that in statute so
the legislature would have had
a say in it but my original uh comment
was um about the uh
the other fishing game part with the
um the
fish derelict fishing gear and um
changing
the name of the fund to leave out the
words fishing for energy was
the uh when i spoke with the prime
sponsor about this
he was very much in favor of that he
said it made it a much clearer thing
and the other part of the amendment that
the
prime sponsor introduced was taking
shrimp out of the equation and that is
because
the shrimp fishery
in the new england is pretty well shut
down
and the facilities for even processing
shrimp have been shut down
because there is because there are no
shrimp so that was the reason for that
being
removed from the bill in case anyone
wondered
that was all i wanted to say
any anyone else just to speak on
me sir
thank you so just back to the zoonotic
uh portion of the book uh
in my mind a couple of things first
is um
if if we know that that uh
these diseases are prevalent based on
who
and uh and that the uh fish and game has
come to us and said hey we need to
do this and then testify that we
shouldn't do it and that they have the
resources
to do it um
i don't know that i would want to be on
the side answering to the
to my constituents saying i could have
done something
but i failed to do it and if if
something
did happen and we had the power to
prevent it
uh via the language of this bill i think
that that's our
responsibility to do that i don't think
there's overreach
um this is the official game doing what
they say
is their job to do we're giving them the
legal background to do that
and uh if there was a cost to it i think
it would have come up as an fn which
and so i think we're just giving them
the authority to act reasonably
as representative smith said in
accordance with government jokes
i think any other any other questions uh
or any questions or comments on this
issue
sir i see no questions all right uh i
just uh called your attention uh
the uh testimony from the fish and game
department
uh where and it was uh
paul sanderson the legal coordinator who
testified in favor
and one of the things he did say in his
testimony was
uh we have worked closely on section
three which is uh
the element we're talking about uh with
senator waters and the department of
agriculture to deal with concerns over
the potential spread
of zoonotic diseases within the state of
new hampshire
and acknowledged that the covet 19
pandemic
has brought this concern to the
forefront in the state and across the
world
as such an expression of concern for the
issue
is warranted in the statutes existing
processes for our two departments
as well as the department of health and
human services
are in place to carefully watch for the
emergence of any issues and to seek
assistance
from the legislature and the governor
when necessary
in addition the requirements of fish and
game law
uh
rsa sets forth a workable process to
respond to challenges when
and if they are identified and we
support the proposal
so fish and uh on the record
did testify in favor uh
i think personally i think uh
the the way
you know the way that this government
operates is
uh the executive branch is very
relatively limited in what it can do
without funding
uh most uh we as the
the we are we basically represent the
people
the legislature and
we provide
the funding and uh in order for
the executive branch to operate and part
of that
uh responsibility of the of that is that
we we tell them what are
what the what the priorities are
or should be it doesn't stop them from
reacting
but it but they do need to be able to
have plans in place
they do uh they do need to
uh be they are expected
i think the gov the government is
expected to think ahead
to think uh don't not not to
wait for the problem to show up but to
anticipate the problem
that doesn't always work but you know
they they do ex they're paying
us and they're paying the
the people are paying uh the legislature
not much but they're paying us uh and
the
but also the the executive branch to
look forward to look
at uh and to plan ahead to plan for
the uh what can happen and
to be the last thing you want to do to
do is to
just you have to is to have a
something happen and you weren't
thinking that you didn't you didn't plan
for it
you know and you know you
when when the when the when an attack
comes
but this and that could be a disease you
fight the battle
what you got with who's who's there what
you what plans you have
and if you don't have any plans then
you're running then you're really in
trouble
that's that's just my
my feeling uh any uh
yes thank you um in reference to your
comments
can i ask generally when there's a bill
like this
why wouldn't there be more specifics in
how
it would be carried out this is the
generalities that i'm really having
problems with and when i talk to other
people they
also express concern for that
so is that is that normal for it not to
really have
any specifics at all it was extremely
general and broad
that that is always an issue with
legislation
you you don't want to micromanage
but you want to make reasonable you like
you
you'd like to make reasonable direction
and that always
is part of the skill of
of legislation uh
sometime it works sometimes it doesn't
sometimes you don't really know
generally you we do have a rule system
so you don't want to go so far into the
in place place things that should be
done in rules
let the rules generated by the
administration
so you don't want to get too deep into
that but there are times when you might
have to
but that that is it's on a case-by-case
basis in this state
in this instance you're you're
giving them a general direction
uh there
they are there may be there may be
follow-ons this is the
this is this is the first step
at least in my in my view
uh did that answer your question
maybe someone else's comparison to other
bills
is this you would say this is a normal
bill that in terms of
uh at this at this point yeah uh
what uh i'll go ask for some help from
any
anyone else and even the
you know this is basically on general
general procedures and general thoughts
you might might you you you know when
you
when you put a bill like this a bill
like this out
which is on this section it's a general
it is it has general uh general
discussions representative
representative gracie is it uh yes yeah
just to give you a hand i mean
you've explained it pretty well and uh
chairman i think that what we do
is we basically set up the the the
structure
and the direction we'd like to see it go
and then the executive branch has to
implement and
develop and implement the rules that
support
the direction we're asking them to move
in so this is not unusual and this is
what most of our bills look like
um we say we need to address this issue
how the technicalities of how we address
it and more in the minutia that's
developed
in the rules within the departments that
are responsible to enforce it
and they have to figure out how they can
enforce something
what they're capable of doing what their
financial
availability is and they make those
rules
to enforce the direction we send them in
thank you does that help yes it did um
my only thought on that is that
we're putting forth something that we
have no idea what the rules are going to
be
and if it's going to work and um
again i just maybe it's a freshman thing
but i i would like to see something
tightened up
or or you know i guess
if we don't like what happens with it as
a legislature we change it
correct yeah absolutely racers do have
pencils who have erasers survive
except that we do pens now
but yes but yeah if there are issues
we will get involved but normally in
such
cases like this uh
there will be issues around funding
things like that
there's always going to be uh
legislation in governing is an iterative
process
yeah we may of course we might not see
this again because this is a sufficient
game bill
so uh but now that you asked a question
also around
the amendments uh
we could you
you there is the ability to put forth an
amendment
we can't just we can take this
portion out as per as an amendment
if uh but uh you know we'd have to have
one and
have to have one put together we'd have
to uh vote on
uh if if you would like we can take a
straw poll uh wouldn't be a
wouldn't fit they'll wouldn't it
wouldn't it would not
be an amendment but if if you uh if you
felt
uh you want you you know you wanted to
see this
section removed you could ask and i
would
i would i would then ask in your behalf
for a uh just a straw poll for who
would look who would like an amendment
who would support an amendment to put
to remove the uh remove this section
uh if it doesn't
you know but if obviously if it doesn't
uh if you don't get a
plurality it's not gonna right
yeah it would be you wouldn't be worth
our time to go and get one right
to vote so it's your choice
so i would like to um see if there was
any interest
in removing it all right
yes a question please
when the fishing game department
testified
on this did they reflect
whether there was current law concerning
tsunami animals uh there
are uh there are a lot of i did not
hear that they were they did say that
there are
a lot and they indicated that there was
laws concerning uh domestic
uh you know domesticated animals
especially around
health and stuff like that uh
i can't recall they're testifying to
whether there were other what what other
laws existed
unfortunately fish and game were sitting
where you
there was the chair in the fishing game
and several other representatives
they were doing a bunch of the
questioning and we were listening
i do not recall any
any mention of the follow-up yeah
it would seem to be that if there isn't
any state law concerning this there
needs to be
some sort of enabling legislation
so that if something happens let's say
we discover that there's diseases that
are being transmitted from
a domestic animal that we currently
let's say bulldogs for instance
all of a sudden we figure out that
bulldogs
transmit disease to humans well then we
would need
something in the statutes to allow
fish and game to take care of that i
would i would probably i would say i
think that there is such data
but you know you have uh in front of the
actual bill itself
just so you can look at the
i have the bill you have the bill you
have the bill
uh what do you say um
146 the original
and it's part three
it goes through uh what
it is as definitions of
this the this is a very the bill is
fairly narrow
if you read the fire if you want a copy
of it
just to be able to do detroit to be able
to read the
specific section of the bill it doesn't
change much of any
the only thing that changes is
but i would i can't i can't
give you a definitive answer on whether
you can or can't uh
what the law of read concerning and the
the powers of fish and game and
in the department of agriculture and the
health and human services
i would be surprised that they didn't
have stuff already in place
around those issues
this is around the mixing of the and
handling
of uh
these these type of these
these uh these type of these
wild the wild animals so yeah i remember
that expanding
smith all right okay uh who is first
congress first
uh let me uh let me
okay okay uh representative spang for
question
or science thank you um
by now the conversation haven't gone on
i have a couple of comments the first
one is relative to rules
um we have found in the past that there
is a serious
problem if we try to put too many
details
into statute because circumstances
change
either outside the state house or within
the agencies that make it impossible
to adjust the way something is supposed
to be handled by the agency
the agency would have the flexibility to
adapt to those changes if it weren't in
statute
and didn't require an act of the
legislature to
tweak basically tweak a procedure
that the agency would be bringing in so
i have great faith in the agencies to be
able to do what they can afford to do
under the circumstances that they are
facing
the other thing is i wanted to mention
that
there are always hearings before rules
while there is rule making going on
and that that's an opportunity for the
people who are affected
to have input into the proposed
rules and also legislators can
participate in those hearings
and influence what they think the rules
should be
so it isn't as though we're just giving
them a carte blanche
and then seeing what they make of it um
and i um i'm also next page i noticed
that
uh section two is
does not relate strictly to the markets
and i agree the market
seems to be kind of um 3 000 miles away
but it would certainly be
embarrassing to be caught in the covet
kind of situation when we've certainly
been well
warned what happens however where it
talks about
wildlife species that are not
part of a market but they're caged and
handled and transported with livestock
or domestic animals
there are really uh severe consequences
when wildlife
carries a disease to a uh
a herd of cattle for example so i think
that this
though the market part of it seems a
little
far-fetched in our current environment
i think that that addressing that whole
problem
of transferring of of
these diseases into our own domestic
animals be they pets or herds
and thence to humans absolutely must be
controlled so you know i think this is a
a matter of an ounce of caution
um and i and when i first saw the bill i
thought
give me a break but the more i thought
about it and the
closer i read it i began to think why
why not take this precaution
okay representative smith for uh comment
a question
uh yeah the the first thing i wanted to
say
is that um those of us who are uh
here remotely have no idea who the
person is who is speaking
in the committee room um unless
you know it's the chair because i
recognize his voice
but um if if we can if
we can hear their name at some point so
we know which
member of which colleague of ours is
speaking that would be helpful
the other comment i wanted to make is we
have a lot of questions that seem to be
directed
um towards fish and game and paul
sanderson's testimony and paul sanderson
is
in the meeting and if we have questions
maybe he could be best
answering them as opposed to us trying
to figure out what he meant
i did i wasn't aware of that
[Music]
and representative smith your admonition
is well received
i will be calling people's names as i
speak to them
and ask that it
be helpful thanks i i apologize
yeah i'm a rookie at this uh
mr sanderson yes thank you mr chairman
i'm here and ready to answer any
question that a member might have
well i i think uh have you been uh
hearing uh some of the discussion that's
uh
yes and i i would give you this comment
with regard to existing laws
you'll note here that this particular uh
bill
looks to add a new section 207 14 a
207 14 already provides us with certain
powers
with regard to importation possession or
release of wildlife
and we in fact have an entire series of
administrative rules
fis 800 uh by which we administer
that particular duty uh we also have
powers that are given to the executive
director in rsa 206
10 gives the authority to deal with
the movement of animals across state
lines that might cause the introduction
of disease
however senator waters identified and we
certainly agree with him
that there is a tremendous opportunity
here for
transmission not only among wildlife but
also among domesticated animals
and what he was really trying to do here
was make sure that the departments are
working together
in order to be both vigilant and to
identify this
and bring the issue to the legislature
and the governor's office in the event
that action is required
so it is it is exactly what the members
have identified it is its authorization
legislation
we do adopt rules they will be placed
into our existing fis 800 series
and it fills in the gap that uh we have
here
with regard to what we've learned from
the cobit 19 experience
i hope that answers your questions uh
one of the questions k uh came up uh
that well why do you need legislation to
be
pointed and you know do this do that
can't you just do that on your own or uh
can you respond to that uh
you know that why you think the
legislation
uh is important to be able to that
that is gives us gives you some kind of
direction
uh thank you for the question mr
chairman the the reason that authorizing
legislation is important is because of
the question of enforcement
we would in fact be looking for these
sorts of things but if we have no
enabling legislation that allows us to
move forward to take action
that might involve the seizure of
particular
items of property or the seizure of
wildlife
cooperation with other departments then
we might be
less able to effectively deal with an
identified threat to human health
we would be doing this in conjunction
with the governor's office the attorney
general's office
the department of agriculture and the
department of health and human services
um we certainly take uh property rights
very seriously but we also take human
disease very seriously
and would not be looking to go out and
do these sorts of things
on our own we recently had an incident
here
uh not involving the transmission of
disease but the transmission of invasive
species
in our case it was question of zebra
mussels that
are invasive species
they were being imported into our state
and being sold as part of
aquatic items that we placed inside fish
tanks
if they had ever escaped and gone out
into the environment they
multiply rapidly have no particular
predators
and can cause tremendous damage to water
systems and sewer systems
so in that case we worked closely with
the u.s fish and wildlife service
closely with the department of
agriculture because they're the ones who
regulate pet stores where these were
being sold
the department of health and human
services and also
governor's office and the attorney
general's office to effectively contain
that particular importation the system
is there
and the system works and it's something
where we take these
these issues seriously but in
cooperation with our colleagues across
the executive branch
uh representative post for a question
from mr sanderson yes thank you mr chair
um so the my question is um
you have something in place so the
addition is
just this part
three is just put in to identify
wildlife not mixing with domestic
and um
the other question on that is um
could you talk about the logistics of
how
the people who have boots on the ground
who
would be looking for this would
how things would happen or traditionally
how they do happen in finding these
types of things
yes if i go back to the example that i
just used
of the zebra mussels the question of
the invasive species moving into the
state was actually first identified by
the u.s fish and wildlife service
and rely upon us as their state partners
to actually implement this within the
state
so when we talk about um the first part
which is
this the scanning the idea of
identifying
issues any agencies in fact
are watching for things like this at
both the federal and state level
once the threat is identified then they
will come to the agency
that is most able to deal with where the
threat seems to be located
if it was dealing for example with
domesticated animals in their movement
they would be going to the department of
agriculture
uh but of course there could be a risk
if there had been exposure to wildlife
along the way and that would involve us
so as we talk about boots on the ground
it really is
this idea of identification and
screening and then trying to develop a
response that is most likely to be
protective of human health
and also respective of private property
rights
i know that's a very general answer but
on the other hand
these issues i think are somewhat unique
as they present themselves
thank you any other
uh any other questions uh
on this issue all right
um thank you mr chair um i
i took that to um you know
the intent of the bill i just had a
question of it says in the bill
um the efficiency department monitor
available
uh general official not currently
restricted
under state and federal wildlife
trafficking laws
is there any so it would be too
difficult to just add these species
to this list or is that is it just
quicker to do it this way
exactly curious about the
uh thank you representative i think your
question is about how the monitoring
occurs is that correct
um yes that that would be helpful
information but
also so you already have restrictions
on species under this current
you know apparently listed a list of
animals
that are restricted under state and
federal wildlife trafficking mode
so if there were a new species such as
zebra mussels or
fats or something would that just be
added to the list
yes yes representative if new species
are identified or new specific threats
are identified we can amend our
administrative rules
in order to determine whether those
particular species
should be taken and placed upon either a
controlled or a prohibited list
and yes those particular
specific species are identified
currently for us in our fis 800 rules
but we would amend them if we had new
information
but this language you want this language
a quicker process
uh thank you representative yes even the
process of amendment with an
administrative rule takes six to nine
months
unless we do something on an emergency
basis so
this particular enabling legislation
would enable us to act within a period
of hours or days in cooperation
with the attorney general's office and
the governor's office to make sure that
any threat to human health or
to the value of private property was
addressed immediately
thank you it answers your question
representative
anyone else there are no further answers
thank you very thank you very much for
your help
mr sanderson uh
okay any other
any other questions on this uh require
comments
uh if you have a well i'll
i'm going to put a ask for a i will ask
for a
straw vote as to whether or not
we would wish to remove this section
from the bill uh anybody who would look
to remove this section from the bill and
uh
should we put forward we would require
putting a ger
require recessing to get a uh an
amendment if it looks like
there would be a a
majority uh all those who who would
uh would favor an amendment
uh please raise your hands
or
one is there anyone on the screen
representative dodge has his handbrake
representative dodge
and representative post
anyone else so i should know what else
no one else
[Music]
uh so it's basically two two people
would uh so
if that would not pass i don't believe
at least that might
at least the way i count i i feel a
little bit
better about it um after you know the
conversation and
the gentleman who spoke um
i
do feel that um
representative harvey bola's question
about um if it could just be kind of
tacked on to what you know they have
initially i guess i still question that
a little bit um in terms of
if they do have that in place is it
strictly just the wildlife portion
that wasn't contained in it that created
this to be put together
i think it's i think it
it might even be narrower than that uh
it's for
those animals in this
[Music]
who are that are considered taxons uh
basically wildlife and it's it is
monitoring for that
so any any animal can any mammal can be
attacked
so yes that's those are wild
right so it is this is wildlife at least
as i read it
and and that's something they didn't
have in there before
and they can't really add it on because
it would take too long
for them to do that in their rules
they can only add things to rules that
were a lot that are
allowed in statute statutes come first
then then you make rules thank you yeah
we get mad when they make rules that
don't
that i don't have statute backing
okay any anyone else
on any poor other portion
of the of the bill
and or of the amendment
so there are no injuries there are no
hands raised
in that case
on the on
i'll call first i'll call for a a vote
on the amendment
and then call for a vote on the bill
[Music]
as amended uh the
the
representative horgan are you there
representative horgan you there
i'm here uh
in the absence of the
uh the vice chair and
in the absence of uh
the uh of the senior
uh republican uh
uh if the you are now the senior
republican
so you will be acting as the vice chair
so you will be the first one
to vote for uh because normally it's the
uh
the uh vice chair who's the first one to
vote so you will be the first one voting
you got that so everything everything
hangs on you now
so okay
representative spain thank you mr chair
um are we going to have no discussion
about any other aspects of the bill
you could ask voting on the entire bill
now right
right you remember yeah we're involved
we'll be voting on the amendment but
uh i said there's any other
discussion on the bill or the amendment
oh okay
i thought we were just going to vote on
the um whether we want to amend it or
not
but there are i think we already did
that
well we already did that was a straw
poll and there would be
how about the other aspects of the bill
uh
go if if you have a concern on any
portion of the bill
now's the time right well i had raised
quite
a hullabaloo about changing the
definition
of a high tide i was
involved in the definition that is
currently
in in statute i called steve kutcher
from
the coastal to program
to ask him about it i was a little
disturbed when i guess
senator sherman brought it in and he's
had a lot of battles with his
shoreline property owners on the beaches
about how close they can build to the
beach and how
where the property line ends where they
can forbid people to be on their beach
so i i thought that we ought to be
looking at the ecological impact
also and also the fact that we're
expecting to have
a sea level rise as senator waters well
knows having done that study
um and i thought looking at 19 years
what starting now
in the in the next 19 years we're
expecting that
lying to move the high water the
average over 19 years of the high tide
is going to move um
so uh i was that whole argument
was obviated by the fact that steve
kutter said
that this change was required by
a court order and it wasn't a case about
a property owner or anything else
it was the particular language
that we have in our statute and they
said that we
must change it according to what this
bill
is asking for so so be it
thank you
thank you very much representative spang
any other
comments or questions on any on this or
any other portion of the
of the bill or of the amen the amendment
to the bill
will i get the amendment number please
the amendment
number is 1573
i've got i have so many papers in front
of me
they all look alike so mr chairman can i
make a motion to
uh ought to pass on the amendment 1573.
uh we
actually we it's on the we have one
already uh
this uh
motion by uh representative crichton
clayton there's a straw
a struggle it doesn't count as a vote
though does it
amendment no pardon i didn't break up
the first part of the question
doesn't you know i think any any formal
vote has to be
right this was not about the this was
uh was a straw vote on whether or not we
would pursue
having an amendment uh to remove
uh part three of the bill okay and uh
we took the struggle and uh if we went
ahead and amendment it would it would
not
it would not be passed right then we
would need a formal vote right yeah okay
uh any other questions on the
or any other questions comments before
we proceed with the
vote on the amendment
no handwriting on the amendment
clerk please call the roll thank you
chair starting with
representative morgan okay
representative organ
yes folks yes
representative yes
our votes yes representative creighton
brainville josh
yes yes representative
uh representative mayville votes yes to
the amendment
they bill votes yes represent the post
representative
post votes yes post votes yes
representative smith you're muted
sorry about that representative smith
yes
yes representative sven yes
thank those guests representative
brassie yes
yes representative scotland yes
representative connors votes yes yes
representative kelly representative
kelly votes yes
yes representative
yes
uh yes yes
yes the amendment passes
on ought to pass
as amended any uh
see no no answer no hands
please call the
uh role oregon yes
morgan votes yes uh representative carb
yes yes or so creighton
yes great yes representative dodge
yes votes yes
yes
senator haley votes yes representative
representative jess
representative smith yes yes yes
representative spang both yes
representative grassy votes yes
yes
representative weston newton if weston
votes yes
western votes yes representative
representative connors votes yes
yes representative dale votes yes
representative kelly representative
kelly votes yes
yes
all right well good side caleb
ask for it not to be on consent if you
do i'll be very angry
go right ahead you can you you say no if
you say
consent because that means it will be
discussed on the floor and i will have
to fight it
and that means that everything would be
looked at individually
yes oh no no no no no
no no no
take that person behind the shed have a
talk
well you want you you do not want you do
not consent
but they can still pull it off you can
pull it off if you change your mind
just notify the clerk you can pull it
off on the floor
yes i'll leave that okay
let's get it number five session before
session yeah
day before you can tell the question
i wouldn't recommend it
no it looks like grandstanding well
let's let's let's keep it let's keep it
don't say anything
no more all right it it is for now it is
on consent
uh that closes the
uh the executive session unless there is
any other thing on the executive session
i think we've done all our work
as far as that i do have
i will close the executive session we do
have
some issues to go over
around
or around the
messages from the senate i don't
think it's a requirement that
any of these folks who substituted and
helped us out
uh say this is uh this is just getting
advice
from uh as a chair from
uh from the rest of the committee on
other bills that the
head of the senate have gotten uh
amended
and they're back before us
i shouldn't have a discussion on those
but you're free to
you're free to go or share or you can
stay
ultimately your decision anyways it's
going to take advice
right it is my decision but to say i
i value the advice and i also it's
if i screw up it's not my fault they
convinced me
representative lasalles can tell when
he's not wanted
to proceed we're gonna we're gonna trust
uh representative
the chairman's in concuring and
non-concurrent
thank you very much all right we have
a uh you find them all i got
so many folders here all right
we have three bills
signed by that have come
back to us from the senate and
you should have i've sent them sent over
over the last couple of weeks
sent over side by sides
from
uh from uh brad greenland
and uh house bill
397 house bill
99 and house bill
let's take the easiest
to the hardest first
okay you have you got a hold of them all
if not i can
that's which one i'm gonna go 397 which
is the easiest one
you have copies of them
i thought i can uh take a few minutes
and
share the screen
okay
uh
actually in front of me uh you can see
that the
the language they've accepted all of our
language
basically but they've just simply added
a segment to it
if you recall this is the uh the act
uh concerning sure uh concerning the
fees
under the shoreline protection act that
was uh
brought to brought here by uh
representative pearl and there was
discussion and negotiation with uh
renee pelletier about uh
during our hearing on what would what
would work
and uh we came came out with uh
uh the the fees would uh would have
would kind of cap
at with the primitive fees would be no
greater than thirty seven
hundred and fifty dollars and that was
what our bill
says and that the and the senate
agreed with that but they also tacked on
a new paragraph
concerning uh the development at uh
at p's development uh and i guess that's
that's in i think greenland but uh
uh where that where the
uh they would add to
the maximum cash application fee for the
peas development authority
division of ports and harbors shelby ten
thousand dollars
per state title peer and docking
facility application
uh
i'll tell you where i stand i'm just i
would just assume concur
because we got all we want they haven't
affected what we want
and they uh somebody from the coast
who has the where the pp's development
is i think that's probably senator
sherman
uh probably uh asked for this so
i have no problem with it but uh
any any thoughts any um any comments
from uh
members of the committee
nope sure there are no hands grace so
there's no hands raised so i'm going to
okay spencer
uh representative smith yeah thank you
mr chair
um i just wanted to say that um
because the the part of the bill that we
passed
says no permitting fee greater than
37.50
3750 and
you could say that p's
some of those applications with peas
could have to do
with you know state and federal uh
money and so therefore it's kind of
upping their ante a little bit because i
think title peers and docking may
be a lot more complicated and so that
lower fee
wouldn't be a good idea for them but
then also it keeps it from going higher
than 10 000.
so i think it's a good i it's i think
it's reasonable i would say to concur
also
any other replies or responses so sir
okay let the records show that the
general agreement
on the uh on the committee on
that we concur that uh send the message
of concurrence
for house bill 397
now let's go to house bill
and that's a little more complicated
this
is the bill relative to seasonal
platforms on public waters of the state
go through you know page
one and two of the uh
of the side by side there's no no
difference
you know the senate version added a
little bit of language
concerning the uh
the platform on
they added ver uh versions that person
who this is this is a concerning
uh
any person erecting and installing
maintaining or exercising control
over an anchored seasonal platform on
any public body
water shell obtain his or attach his or
her name
in contact information to any such
seasonal platform
as provided in this subdivision
and in accordance with rules established
under rsa
2 70
72 g
and that's that's fine at least i think
i think it is
any any comments on that there's also a
they
added an additional section that the
seasonal
platform shall be installed on public
waters that support
a local state or signal platforms
installed on public waters
that's that support a local state or
federal government agency
or agency subcontractors or a
conservation group
engaged in the non-recreational
activities may be
installed provided the platform meets
the minimum requirements established in
270.
270 dash of colon 72d
so they added that section
uh
don't see an issue with that
uh they're they're
they're all they're basically allowing a
are they saying that
the they have to be
they should they're allowed
these there's a they act
they've they've added location instead
of prohibited
and the in the next set of lines the 270
anchored seasonal platform prohibited
they say change that to location
it doesn't i don't get any heartburn to
that
representative smith do you have uh
thanks
mr chair um i was just gonna
um clarify a few
things um which is uh and
on the last page of the side by side uh
on their exemptions that the house did
exempting um the agencies and the
subcontractors doing
non-recreational execution of their
duties and
um in the side by side it says the
senate removed these exemptions
however actually what they did is they
moved
the exemption
to section three on page three
and says seasonal platforms that support
local state or federal government
agency subcontractors or conservation
groups shall be allowed to
do platforms etc so it's kind of in
there but they didn't put it in
exemptions
they put it in what could be allowed and
then
also uh we had pretty much just
said uh the person whose um
platform is removed has to reimburse the
department and the senate went into
great detail on how that would happen
and how long marine patrol would hold on
to
the platform and uh so they just
made they made it a lot tighter the bill
i think so i think it's a
i think they made good changes don't
always agree with them but
in this case i think they did yeah i
mean there's nothing in here
nothing i see on this bill they've made
a lot of changes but
they're all either nothing that
nothing that i would go to war over uh
it's so i'm just going i would just
concur
at least that's where i'm leaving that's
what i'm leaning forward
no other hands up can i
i'd concur okay thank you that's uh i
think that's what i'm
that's where i'm that's where i'm
leaning that's where i think i'm gonna
be going
so uh on
with the records show that uh
the uh i will be going to
i will be going on house bill 99
uh i will be
is uh i will concur
no this is uh just 0.99 or 99.
i will i'll be concurring
and uh that get the
general consensus of the uh we have the
consensus of the war
of the uh of the committee
no issue
okay and
all right uh comparison of the
uh now we go to 235.
this one this one's going to be a little
a little bit different
uh 235 was the
brown small groundwater withdrawal bill
we had passed uh it passed this
committee unanimously
the year before or the session before it
also passed unanimously
now this year
the exact same bill and they don't they
didn't have any problem with it
what they did is they tacked on a
some revisions to
the the
pfas fund and programs which is a
large multi-million dollar
fund concerning uh
goods concerning road remediation
programs for
uh pfast issues
the what has concerned my
myself and and others
representative smithsmith was in
particular having been the former
chairman
under her uh under her administration
there was a bill very similar
to uh the
almost very similar to the uh
the uh well uh the uh excuse me to the
the pfast fund there was a house bill
but that
died of covet and
it was very similar to the senate
version we said one main difference
it did not have anything in it
protecting or giving aid
to homeowners individual well owners
and that concerns us
so considering this is
non-concurring and requesting a
committee of conference
uh representative smith you want to
help me out a little a little bit more
on your background and the
comments sounds good thanks mr chair um
as as jiren zulu said we had a bill
that established
the pfas remediation fund
and it passed resources it passed the
house it went to ways and means
it passed the house again and then
session pretty much closed down for the
year and
the senate added most of the bill we had
passed to an
omnibus bill which passed and formed
this pfas uh remediation
contamination and remediation fund
however
when we passed the bill out of resources
and the house passed it
we included municipalities in the people
who could apply
as well as uh private land
private homeowners whose wells had been
contaminated by pfas
now when the senate put it in their
omnibus bill they left out
municipalities
and private well owners
and then this year in
what they have done to our house bill
which we not only passed and the senate
agrees with
they also they put
they changed the pfas fund
to include municipalities but they still
neglected
to address the private wells and how
people who have private wells and have
been living on bottled water
for like two years and
still have no no avenue for redress
on that issue on getting their water
cleaned up
we thought it was really important to
add that so by having
one thing that we would request in a
committee a conference was adding
private well owners
or assuring that by adding
municipalities private well
owners were going to be covered and
there's nothing in the amendment that
the senate put on which
uh indicates that private well owners
would be helped
the other um change that the senate made
was they changed in the purpose
statement
of the pfas remediation fund
the words per and polyfloral substances
pfas to perfluorochemical contamination
and i was very concerned about this
because
uh we have we already have a bill that
we passed this year
um that changes the wording from
um to
per and polyfloral substances rather
than just
pfas or per floral chemicals
so um i reached out to the
senate sponsor and also to mike wimsat
at des
and um mike explained why
this language needed to be in and
pretty much it will not change how
um any the maximum contaminant levels
mcl's
uh law which we passed last year which
requires
uh pfas it gives makes it clear
that uh the amount of pfas that is
allowed in drinking water
and so it it actually clarifies this
so that those mcls will be just
you know it won't change anything in how
we address that law
of the mcl's i know that sounds
confusing but
um anyway so i would support the
the as as of right now unless i hear
more in between now and the committee a
conference
i would support that part but uh we do
have big concerns both chair renzolo and
i and probably anyone who was on this
committee last year
and fought to have private well owners
included
um would want us to try to get that
included in the bill
and then the bottom line the
the next bottom line is that if we
cannot come to agreement with the senate
on a in a committee of conference and
they won't budge
on the private well owners we have saved
the small groundwater withdrawals which
is the main piece of this bill
by putting it in the bill we just passed
a few minutes ago
that's called politics
or belt and suspenders that's right belt
and suspenders
that represent representative creighton
yeah mr chair i just
uh from my perspective in
in digit 38 i would estimate that less
than
40 percent of the people fall under city
water of some sort
and so the pirates of people are on well
water
and so if you
thank you uh any other uh any other
comments
representative harvey bowling thank you
mr chair
um i uh of course i'm in favor of
helping the private well owner with
the terrible circumstance of the key
fast contamination in there
well um i'm just
wondering about the process here because
it was my understanding
that you know say a homeowner has
contamination they should you know act
immediately for one um
and then this would i thought would
incur like a lawsuit
okay you've got fast it's obviously not
coming from the
homeowner uh it's coming from maybe
nearby
station
those sort of procedures you know
go up to the state hazardous waste a
superfund site
or a hazardous waste cleaning up site
and they sort of handled
the monetary part of the cleanup but
there was a system of redress to my
knowledge
mr chair it's really difficult
for me anyway to hear the people who are
in the room
so i get about half of what the last two
speakers have said
i'm sorry uh
can uh maybe
you've got the
that's not there representative smith
can you hear me
now yes now i can hear you find that
your microphone is over here
um just really quickly i i am in favor
of course
nobody wants to leave a homeowner with
no redress
if they have heat fast contamination in
their wells
um thank you but i i was under the
impression that there was already a
system in place
uh through the state for hazardous waste
cleanup is
is there not can you speak to how that
that they are left out of a process of
hazardous waste cleanup in the state
thanks we have the drinking and
groundwater trust fund
and which provides money
to municipalities and water systems
and and it's pretty much the pfas
loan and grant remediation program would
operate within that drinking and
groundwater trust fund i believe or they
would
be working side by side but there is
nothing
in that in either of those
that allow a private well owner to
ask for remediation funds
now one of the arguments against the
private well owners
applying is because there would be so
many people applying it would be all
these small
individual claims and by adding
municipalities
to this uh amendment
there is thought that that could help
that situation
but i'd like to see it a little more
clear rather than oh yeah municipalities
can then help the private well owners
i'd like it to be more
clear that the municipalities would be
applying
on behalf of private well owners to
either hook them up to town water
or provide filtration systems for them
because right now the private well
owners as far as i know with the pfas
anyway are
are left out of the picture as far as
mtbe
goes um i don't know if private
owners were given remediation
on that but i know that right now for
pfas uh
they are not getting remediation
and um and and the
pfas uh fund as well as the drinking and
groundwater trust fund
um are both
not where you get 100 you get 25 to 50
of the cost and it could be grants or
loans and they're
in those thumbs are looking for matching
money
so it's it's it's a very complicated
process
does that help at all i know it's so
thank you
yeah i think uh also that
we've you know the mtb funds was kind of
the model for
of how handling contamination
lawsuits uh
occurred that that was that
fund was uh was populated
with money from a loss from a lawsuit
uh that that the state
uh sued on behalf of uh well the state
and the
and the various towns and that that
money
is is being used for
not not simply for mtbe
uh remediation but also for uh
other uh capital
uh capital water
uh water fund water funding um
and there will be there's well there's
all there is always
discussion around the
probable lawsuit uh
against the manufacturers of the
pfast entities and
expect expectation is for a a
significant settlement
so
[Music]
with that uh okay
then i'm gonna uh
non-concur and request the committee of
conference
and uh any any for
any other thoughts on that
no answers that's what we will do i will
move forward on these three anything
else that uh
we can talk uh we need to to talk about
the uh any issues that uh
before we before i uh hit the gavel to
adjourn
it will be uh i i will i will write the
blurb on on this bill
luckily i got a lot of things that are
pretty all pre-written i think you can
paste a lot of stuff together
uh and uh
representative smith for uh do we know
if there are any more senate bills
coming our way back with changes
or are we pretty much finished i have
not heard of any more
uh no more have been given to me uh
uh and i haven't gotten an alert of any
more
uh hearings usually the uh the commit
the committee assistant does alert me
when one of our builds uh is
is appearing before our committee and
i have not gotten anything since the the
last ones
okay and secondly anything on retained
bills
uh we could not touch retained bills
until we're finished here
so we're now finished here
so uh so
yeah we should start thinking about them
you know but when what we might want to
what we might want to talk about on the
retain bills
we probably should have a work session
uh
i think you and i
is as the
head as the republican half and the
democrat half the committee we will
we will discuss a good time to uh
have a uh to have retain
to some discussion of retained bills
realizing we can
talk about them we can uh
we but we cannot take a vote
until sometime in november
i think it's uh i think it's
the third week in november
to actually dispose of
but we can you know do do very do
various things
and we should if unless somebody's
taking a
long vacation
any other any other questions any other
thoughts
so there's no answers okay uh
that being the end i'll call this
meeting the rest just
we're done thanks everybody
thank you bye thank you